es el último bastión de resistencia
ucraniana en el asediado puerto de
mariupol la planta siderúrgica de aseos
tal tras varios días de intentos
fallidos para evacuar a civiles
las tropas ucranianas hicieron un pedido
desesperado a la comunidad internacional
este jueves la vice primera ministra de
ucrania reiteró el llamado a las fuerzas
rusas para que permitieran urgentemente
la evacuación de civiles y soldados
heridos hay alrededor de 1000 civiles y
unos 500 soldados heridos todos
necesitan ser sacados diasoft al hoy el
gobierno ucraniano ha culpado a
militares rusos de entorpecer los
intentos de evacuación por medio de
corredores humanitarios esta semana
cuando autobuses organizados por rusia
no entregaron a tiempo los evacuados
hasta el punto de espera de las
ambulancias de ucrania necesitamos un
descanso después del bombardeo después
de toda esta pesadilla hemos vivido en
sótanos durante 30 días
queremos ir a casa de mi hijo ya me está
esperando mamá cuando vas a venir
pregunta compre un tiquete justo antes
del 24 que empezó la guerra y desde
entonces no ha podido ir a los combates
en mariupol al sureste del país han sido
devastadores en donde se contabiliza que
más de 100.000 personas todavía están
atrapadas con pocos suministros de
comida agua o medicinas ahora rusia
asegura controlar por completo el puerto
de mariupol de confirmarse sería una
victoria mayor para el kremlin tras casi
dos meses de guerra y le permitiría
avanzar en sus objetivos de una nueva
fase del conflicto enfocado en lo que
califica como la liberación del donbass